Yeah.
Thank you all for coming today
for this talks at Google.
I'm on anxiety and kids,
um, where Dr Jana courts,
we'll be talking about her book,
Heroic Henrietta,
which is a children's book aimed at
helping kids and parents deal with anxiety
in our kids or for the
kids and themselves. Um,
so I want to introduce Dr Jana carts.
You rented her own practice in Boston,
asthma at psychology and Andy Hirsch
who is a teacher who helped with the
illustrations. So I will let them
come up and get the stock started.
Thank you for coming.
Okay.
Um, so like Danielle said,
my name is Dr Jana. Cora.
I am a licensed clinical psychologist and
I also specialize in treating children
adolescence. I own a boutique group
therapy practice that's in Cambridge,
Boston and Nantucket.
And we have about 10 clinicians that
work for us and they treat children,
teenagers and adults both for therapy
and neuro psych and psych testing,
which I'll show you what we'll touch upon
a little bit later about what that is.
Um, and this is Annie, so she'll
introduce herself in a second.
I just wanted to start by actually
telling the story of how we met,
which is sort of, which is
relevant to this conversation. Um,
so I had always wanted to
make a book like this. Um,
and actually we're turning it into a
series which I will also touch upon later
because anxiety is a really a big issue
for a lot of people and especially
children and it's very misunderstood.
It's misdiagnosed and I thought it would
be really important to have an easy
access book where kids could understand
what was happening to them and also
parents could understand
and help their kids with it.
So I was taking a shower last summer.
It was very hot out. I was, you know,
getting ready to go to a dinner party.
And this book just came to my,
like just came to me and um,
a lot of the stanzas rhyme and it
was all flowing through my mind.
I was like really jazzed about
it. So I get a shower, I'm like,
we're going to be late for this thing.
And my husband was so mad and I was like,
just like dripping now. Like writing
it all down. It was really exciting.
So I'm like really excited about this
book and I can't wait to tell my friends
about it. So I, you know, I busted
into this dinner party super late. Um,
you know, and everyone's sort of looking
at me like a Kramer hindrance, you know,
and I'm like, I, I came up with this
book about this Unicorn that has anxiety,
it's for kids. And I came up with it
in the shower. Isn't that awesome?
And everyone just stared at me and was
very like sort of scattered, you know.
And except for Annie who had only met a
couple of times before who came up to me
and said it was really interested
in hearing more about it.
So I told her a little bit about my idea.
She read a stanza, she took my notebook,
she sketched out what you see behind you.
And she explained,
explained to me that she was a teacher
and she also felt this book was really
important.
And obviously we went for it and we have
another one coming out in a month or so.
And so I will let any doing a brief
introduction of herself and then we'll get
going. So as Dan said, I'm Hirshhorn. Um,
I am here because I illustrated the buck.
Um,
but I also do come from the perspective
as Jana said of having taught for the
past seven years.
I taught in independent schools in
Seattle and then most recently spent three
years here in Boston teaching
in charter schools. Um,
so when we sort of get to the Q and, a,
which is often the most fun with kids,
at least, I'm sure it's adults too.
Um, I would love to talk about Antioch,
Austin's about illustrating,
but also I do have that perspective and
I'm going to share a bit about just sort
of what the teacher viewpoint is working
with kids who show symptoms of anxiety,
what it looks like working with parents.
Um,
and so if you have questions about that
as well. Yeah, and we're pretty informal,
so if you guys want to interrupt,
feel free and you can throw those.
Although I prefer if you just interrupted.
Um,
so the way we're going to work it today
is we will start and talk a little bit
about anxiety,
namely generalized anxiety disorder,
and we'll talk about symptoms both in
terms of cognitive and physical symptoms
of that.
We'll then talk about the treatments that
people will use or ways that they can
help themselves,
which will be told through Henry
on his journey and her book there.
So that's sort of the main
outline and obviously you guys,
if you have questions do interrupt.
So we also are going to focus mainly on
generalized anxiety disorder there and
we'll just call it Gad for short.
Um,
there are a lot of other kinds
of anxiety disorders that exist.
So things like social phobia,
OCD,
those are pretty popular
ones that people know about.
So we are not going to
touch upon that today.
So we're just going to really focus on
this because this is what the book is
about. And usually this is what
affects a lot of individuals.
I'll also say that we
talking about children,
but a lot of this applies
to adults as well.
You would just sort of
sophisticate the language. So,
I don't know if that will be relevant,
but I won't say that every time,
but just know it does
apply to adults as well.
And then this thing I wanted to
ask everyone, does everybody,
does anyone know what the DSM is? Have you
guys heard of that? You do? You do. Okay.
Um,
for those of you who don't,
it is the book that lists all the
recognize psychological disorders and they
come out with a new one every couple
of years. And so this is the criteria.
They say, you know, the symptoms that you
must meet the coach have criteria for a,
for Gad. Um, one thing just
to keep in mind, just I think
it's kind of interesting.
So the book changes over time.
So people,
they will take in and out different
diagnosis. And the most common,
most popular one from the last
iteration of all this is Asperger's,
which is a really popular
diagnosis for quite some time.
But they actually took it out of this
most recent DSM and now those individuals
are supposed to be encompassed more
under autism spectrum or social
communication disorder.
So things vary over time.
But right now this is what,
what we're looking at and this is sort
of what a lot of the physicians and
psychologists recognize and think
about when they think about generalized
anxiety disorder.
So not surprisingly,
this is about excessive worry and
being unable to control that worry.
There's also a variety of other
symptoms that are pretty typical,
including really can read them
restlessness. I can't even read them.
Oh, being easily fatigued, right?
Concentration, irritability,
muscle tension and sleep disturbances.
That can also be appetite
problems as well.
And really it's sort of having these
things happen to you and also sort of
meeting the threshold of
impairing functioning.
So that's sort of the threshold
that psychologist also think about.
Does this impact you really put up quite
a bit to the point that social stuff is
very difficult. Occupational stuff's
very difficult school, things like that.
So that's kind of the threshold there.
And just relating to that,
this is sort of the beginning of
definitely where the psychologist and the
teachers and parents all come together.
We obviously can see a lot
of these at school. Um,
I found I was spending a lot more
hours with a lot of the kids,
then their parents, um, just naturally
how the hours of school go. So,
so of course we do see some of this.
Um,
but of course it's where it can really
important for us to be communicating that
to parents and also parents sort
of communicating with the AC to us.
Other symptoms are that are
pretty common or sematic symptoms,
which I'm sure a lot of you know about.
But basically sematic symptoms are
physical manifestations of psychological
difficulties and important to keep
in mind too is that these are pretty,
can be pretty severe and these are
things that people do experience.
So the example I like to give is I think
we've all had a time where maybe we've
had like the stomach flu or something
pretty gross like that and it's really
painful and just knocks us out.
And so people who have anxiety can have
symptoms that severe but without sort of
the virus or the medical component.
So we'll see a lot of kids who come in,
they've been to four or five different
doctors and nobody can corner come up
with a reason why they might be having
stomach aches or headaches or something
like that.
And that's when they sort of get referred
to us for therapy because they think
that, you know, the mind body
connection there is pretty strong.
That's again,
a lot of this we will see at school,
kids ask them to put their head down,
no, I just feel tired. We noticed that,
you know,
they're regulated like not taking the
school lunch and not just because it looks
unappetizing there's like a real change.
Um,
and that's often a time where we do
sort of reach out to parents and, Hey,
have you noticed anything?
And we've found that sometimes
parents don't realize it's,
that it's good to communicate with
the school things like, oh yeah,
Bobby hasn't slept for three nights.
Like that might be part of it.
And we're like, Oh God, that would have
been really good to know. Um, that, that,
that makes sense. Um, so I
think we feel like, you know,
that it's a really important opportunity
where we share what we're seeing,
but really,
really helpful to the school when parents
give feedback and we start to get a
more complete picture.
And I think sometimes that can be
missed. Two, because kids have a lot of,
they're not necessarily sophisticated,
sophisticated enough to have the language
to speak very specifically about these
things. So it's sort of like,
you know, my, my body hurts.
I don't want to go to school.
Sort of crying,
not really being able to
articulate these things.
And I think that's sort of also
where, you know, school, um,
participation and things like that come
play. So here we go with Henrietta.
So the first,
well I would say as the first treatment,
what kind of treatment and technique
that we put in the book, um,
was partly cognitive behavioral therapy,
which is CBT for short.
I know a lot of you are
pretty familiar with CBT,
but basically the idea behind it is sort
of figure out how your cognitions are
affecting your actions,
behavior,
emotions and where that's
getting people into trouble.
And a lot of that's based in what we
call cognitive distortions, which,
I mean there are many of them,
but things like black and white thinking,
catastrophizing,
fortune telling,
which is sort of thinking you can predict
the future generalization and things
like that. So we kind of look at those
cognitions and then we say, okay, what,
what is the percentage
chances is going to happen?
What are alternative explanations and
is this really a risk factor for you?
So we'll take Henrietta
here for as an example.
So she's afraid she's going to get an f.
So you know, we see this a lot in kids,
but their train of thought is pretty
long and distorted and that, you know,
I'm gonna fail this test and then my
teacher is going to be mad at me and then
I'm not going to have any friends and
they're not be able to go to school and my
life will be over. And you know,
that's really how they feel.
And so what we do is we first try
to search for some facts, right?
And we wouldn't necessarily do this with
a kid who is not proficient at school,
but we'll just assume that Henrietta is
a good student. And we would say, okay,
like have you historically failed a lot
of tests? You know, what are your grades?
And sort of wondering about that in
terms of what you're afraid of is not
necessarily congruent to
what's happened to you before.
We might also talk about other things
that could happen, you know. Okay,
so you could get an a, you could fail,
but could you get a B? Could you get a c,
could you get a d? What does that
look like? Is there extra credit?
Like is the test cancel
because there's a fire alarm?
Like it could be a number of things.
And then we would look at sort of the
percentage chance of each of those things
happening. And with kids,
you know, who are younger,
you'd sort of modify the language but
they can kind of understand if you do like
pie charts and things like
that. And over time, you know,
you want to let them understand that
the percentage chance of these very
individual things lining up to have this
catastrophic ending sure as possible
but probably not very likely.
And so how likely is it really?
And you would just sort of put percentages
based on those things to kind of get
a more realistic understanding of what
is going on. So Henry and is doing that,
just searching for facts.
She's doing a great job.
Deep breathing is another one that's
really popular, especially with kids. Um,
and as part of the mindfulness movement,
which I know a lot of people are also
familiar with and I will actually touch
upon that at the end.
So kids are actually really good at
this because a lot of kids as they're
younger, they breathe out of their
bellies instead of their chests.
And as we become adults,
we read more with our chest and
belly breathing actually triggers the
parasympathetic nervous system,
which is the nervous system
that's associated with resting.
And so they're already sort of
predisposed to be good at this.
And so we have them sort of lie down
oftentimes with younger kids will do the
visualization piece. So you
can see here at Henrietta, uh,
has her a little boat and
her island and um, yeah. And,
and the plane and you know, we have
kids lie down and they take, you know,
like beanie babies or whatever.
Kids have these days,
a little toys and you'd have them put it
on their stomach and they would try to
try to see if they could make the animal
go up and down and that sort of how you
teach it to them.
And it can be really helpful.
I think a lot of people may see it as a,
like a little hippy dippy,
but it does actually work.
There's a lot of research about that.
So we had Henrietta try that out, she's
killing it. And I find that adults,
when I have talked to them and show them
the book or like this is, this is me,
this is the one I liked the best.
This is my life.
So I find this is often a page that
adults identify with. Yeah. Yeah.
And like I said, a lot of it does
apply to adults. Um, and you know,
you can do it with or without
the visualization piece as well.
This is my favorite one.
So asking for help is actually something
that a lot of people don't consider
would be very difficult for kids,
but especially if they're anxious.
They like the idea of asking
for help and being exposed.
He's like horrifying to them.
So just making a plan of where they
get anxious the most. Who can they ask,
how can they ask, when do they ask?
And having a really concrete plan.
And that's really helpful because not
only do they feel better having the plan,
you know,
so that helps reduce their anxiety,
but they also feel comfortable that
the plan that they have is not going to
expose them in some way. Like the other
students aren't going to find out.
Maybe they have a code word
with the teachers, you know,
they can do it any which way.
But really making a solid plan for as
many scenarios as possible like throughout
their day or the activities is a really,
really good one.
And I mean it works obviously very well.
So I don't know if you ever had that at
school with you know, a little secret.
Yeah.
Just situations eating their timeout
and whether it was like a formal IEP
diagnosis,
if we were at that phase or it was just
sort of they were manifesting some of
these symptoms that yeah, there are ways
that we can work out to take that time.
Um, you know, for them to take that
time that they need. And I also,
I did a picture of a coach in this one.
I sort of um,
brainstorm with my own partner
and with Janet about, you know,
what is that support network looking like?
You just sort of a visual reminder
that like there are more than,
there's parents, there's
teachers, there's your doctors,
but there's also like you have other
adults and networks in your life.
And I think my partner spice
because he's a soccer coach,
he was like definitely a cut.
But the point being that maybe sometimes
we forget and especially kids like how
wide are network of support is.
Yeah, that's a really good point.
So worry time is also a really great one.
Um,
and this can be done
several different ways.
So obviously its little self explanatory,
but basically you give kids a certain
period of time during the day that they
can just let those thoughts run wild.
So whatever they want to worry about,
ruminate about,
that's fine.
Obviously you have to tailor that to kids
depending on how anxious they are and
who they are.
So you know,
two minutes and an anxious child
life is a really long time.
So you'd want to sort of work with
them to figure out what is actually
manageable. And it could be, you
know, 30 seconds, four times a day.
It really just depends. And they would
have this time to just let it all out.
And then the idea would be like,
okay,
now I'm gonna put it in this box and
I'm going to shelve it for later.
And this is helpful for a
lot of different reasons,
but there's also sort of like a
Meta anxiety that people have.
So not only are they anxious, but now
they're anxious if they're anxious.
And so there can be a lot of
additional worry about, you know,
if I don't think about
these things all the time,
I won't find out the solution
and won't be able to help myself.
And so knowing that you
have this time to do that,
it makes it actually easier to
not think about those things, uh,
over the course of the rest of the day.
And a lot of people will talk about like,
well, just don't think about it, think
about something else. But you know,
if someone tells you not to think
about a giant pink polar bear,
like just really don't think about that.
All you're gonna think
about is dry pink over.
So it's a really hard thing for kids
to do or anybody really. And um,
younger kids, well teenagers like
this, do they pretend they don't,
but they do is when you can actually
have a physical box where, you know,
kids will write down their worries and
put it in there and maybe the box has a
lock on it.
And that's a way for them to really have
this concrete place where things are
actually held. And especially
for kids who have an imagination.
I mean they all have imaginations,
but kids who are really imaginative,
that's really helpful too because they
really do imagine it to hold these things
for them, which is really nice. Um,
and teenagers do like it as well.
So back to mindfulness. Um, again,
mindfulness is probably something
you guys are familiar with,
but the basic concept is trying
to keep your mind in the present.
And this is especially relevant to anxiety
because a lot of anxiety is based on
things that have happened in the past as
well as things that are going to happen
in the future and very
rarely as anxiety based.
And what is happening like right now.
So helping kids kind of focus
back to now it can be really,
really successful and
reducing their anxiety.
So bubbles isn't an easy way to
do that because it's an activity.
Kids really like it and you
can kind of try to get them to,
how big can it get before it pops
or how far can it go before it pops?
Or can you get four little
bubbles in one really big one.
And so they're focused on that and
that kind of allows them to become more
present in the moment. Other things, kids
love textures of all, they love food,
but textures of food is a great
way to also do mindfulness.
And I really like using raisins because
they're kind of weird on the outside
with the texture and the inside is
different. They're a little granular,
it's sweets.
You have kids really eat something and
then really explain what it is they are
eating and does the tastes change
over time in like immense detail.
And that can also be a
mindfulness activity. Observing
details kind of similar.
You live on a busy road,
you sit with them outside and you say
how many blue cars can you spot in six
minutes or whatever it
is. Um, yeah, so those,
those are really good activities.
I actually for adults,
and it was like to add this in, I did
not know that you can balance an egg.
I don't know everyone. I mean I
didn't know that until Grad school.
You can actually balance x like this way.
And so trying to get an act to
balance is actually really hard.
So that is also considered a mindfulness
activity because you're focusing on
these sort of various specific
movements of this egg. And so that's,
it can bring you back to the beginning.
We just wanted to touch upon medications.
I am not a psychiatrist,
I do not prescribe medications,
but I think a lot of people sort of
see anxiety and medication as one.
And this is just in the story,
you know,
Henrietta skills work really well so
she doesn't need to take any medication.
And that is just to point
out that sometimes it's
helpful, sometimes it's not.
And just to keep those different
possibilities in mind. Um, again,
they can be really helpful and really
necessary for a lot of people for a lot of
things. But sometimes just giving kids
just a little bit more coping skills and
different strategies is really
pretty effective. And it's enough.
And in teaching it's, I've
seen a wide range of, uh,
especially because I have
mostly taught sixth grade.
So the kids are really
coming in to middle school.
They're bodies are really
starting that change. So the
physical, emotional, social.
So it's a time when a lot of things like
anxiety might start to really manifest
at the same time. It's a time when
parents are not sure about medication,
they're concerned, they're just maybe
starting to talk to a pediatrician.
They relaxed and talk to a pediatrician.
Um,
and then sometimes when we
do have students who families
do you make the choice
to try medication.
Um,
it's another time where
it's really important for us
to be reporting what we're
seeing at school and then
to reporting back to us.
Maybe seeing a theme of what teachers
love when it comes to parents.
Like tell him this. But you see,
um, because it is a time, you know,
I've seen students who are really assisted
in some ways the medication and at
the same time there are side effects
that are concerning. You know, they,
they're not eating, they're not showing
that same aspect of their personality.
And it's just an important conversation.
It can have a wide range of impacts
on a wide range of kids. And it's so,
so great when parents and teachers
can have that back and forth. Right.
So other considerations that we'll talk
about really briefly before the question
section, if you guys have
any, um, anxiety versus Adhd,
which is my favorite thing to talk about.
And also our role as caregivers and
some things to keep in mind if you are
having or you're around
kids were having anxiety.
So anxiety and ADHD especially in
children can look virtually the same.
So things like difficulty concentrating,
irritability, hard time sitting,
still not able to pay attention, not
able to remember anything those can eat.
Both of those fall into these
symptoms of anxiety or Adhd.
So our practice actually gets a ton
of referrals for neuropsych testing,
which is basically the standardized
measures that we give kids that help us
understand how their brain is working.
So things like verbal ability,
nonverbal ability,
processing speed,
all the things with executive functioning
that have to do with Adhd. So planning,
organization, impulsivity,
things like that.
And that's how you really get
a clear diagnosis of Adhd.
And a lot of now a lot of
psychiatrists won't actually prescribe,
especially to kids without that.
So we get,
we see a lot of that in our practice
of what's going on for this person.
And honestly,
more times than not,
we're taking away ADHD diagnoses because
it really is a lot of anxiety and we
actually have separate test to
test that to [inaudible]. Um,
and so we will kind of use both
of those tools to figure that out.
But kids in general,
you know,
they have like three or four symptoms
that they have no matter what's going on
for them. So they're externalizing, so
they're causing their behavioral problems.
They're causing a Ruckus,
they're internalizing,
so they're anxious or they're depressed
or they are just sort of not paying
attention.
And I wouldn't say dissociating,
but they're kind of in their own world.
They're kind of spacey. And over time,
all of those symptoms become more and
more specific and sort of blossom into
different things. So it often look,
things look very similar in the beginning.
So something to keep in mind. And then
also just as our role as caregivers, um,
you know, our own anxieties can be
transferred to children really easily.
They are very perceptive and they pick
up things that are amazing that you think
they would never pick up. And so,
and I know for like my own self,
like my mom grew up in the Bronx
and like a pretty bad neighborhood,
so she's really adamant about lock
checking. So doors, windows, cars,
even though we grew up in a neighborhood
where people have their doors open all
the time.
And so I now in anyone will tell you
yesterday I always shy even the lack
checkers, especially if the doors
as we two or three times. Yeah.
Just one more time.
Um,
and that's not because I really
think that it's not locked.
Just sort of this anxiety
I picked up from my mom,
so we can definitely do that to our
kids or other kids were taking care of,
and it's not our fault,
but just something to be mindful of.
So if we're able to sort of manage that
a little bit, we can. Um, also the,
the rule of reassurance, it was really
hard to negotiate because, you know,
when a kid comes to you and
they're distressed and you know,
they're wondering like, you know, is this
going to happen? Is that going to happen?
You always want to say like, no, it's
okay, these are going to be fine.
But the problem with that is if they are
coming too often and they're doing that
a lot,
then they're not actually learning how
to manage the anxiety of themselves and
then they're sort of relying more on
you and then that becomes a problem too
because you know,
you're not there all the time and
maybe they're in a classroom where the
teachers in doing that or maybe they're
just sleep over and no one can answer
that question for them and they have
a really hard time managing and,
and it kind of explodes and gets worse.
So it's kind of a funny line to find.
I don't necessarily know,
I don't have any specific
guidelines but where that line is,
but it's just something to think
about and also work with teachers and
technologist and alike.
Yes, that's my final plug.
I have found that with all these
things, you know, it's, it is really,
really great and important. Um, when
we're having that communication, you know,
parents telling us what they see if they
have concerns as being able to share
back. It's just like we pretty much
covered the whole day if we do that. Um,
and I think also parents being
able to share concerns, um,
make use of things like school
social worker, school counselor,
psychologist that said,
I've worked in a school that didn't have
any of those things. Um, and so, you know,
hoping that you all feel
empowered is parents of like,
if that's not something
that they had to say, like,
have you thought about networking
other places? Do you have, um,
an outside group that you bring in to be
advocating for your child of like what
an important thing that is tough
to have an offer to students? Yeah,
absolutely. And just along
those lines too, I mean we've
said this the whole time,
but just being mindful to monitor symptoms
and also see if there's some kind of
correlation between when
things are going on,
like in terms of symptoms and
also things going on in the world.
So the first thing that a psychologist
will ask you when you bring your kid to
therapy is to are those connections?
Do they exist, do you know about them?
And if not, then they have every
been start to monitor those anyway.
So things like time of day, exercise
level, you know, it could be anything,
seasons, food they ate
that day, et cetera.
It's important to keep
that in mind as well.
So that is mostly what
we have for you today.
In the back of the book there are two
worksheets which are just to help kids
checkoff and kind of have a behavior
chart of coping strategies that Henrietta
uses in the book. And so
that's in there too. Um,
if anyone has any questions about
getting help or anything about the
presentation. My cards are up here and
we do have a new book coming out soon.
It's called Dorky,
Dorky and he's a half an hour while half
Orca who social skills problems various,
he fell down the stairs.
Someone pushed him anyway.
It is sad but he's
becoming aware of his body.
So He's getting there. He gets
there more than that. He's great.
He's very popular at the anti,
has a lot of friends.
You find a support network and that's it.
So you had talked about the difference
that Adhd and anxiety can be confused.
I asked specifically because my son has
been diagnosed with Adhd and I'm curious
what those differences are and how
you see differences between them
in terms of the testing,
like how we would know that
or testing would be interesting.
I guess I'm also curious just what the
symptoms are or how they do get confused.
Okay,
sure.
So I think what can happen a lot of
times too is we get stuck on the symptom
that interferes with school
the most and that can,
and you know with both kids and anxiety,
right?
They're not necessarily concentrating,
they're not paying attention
or they're running around.
And so that's what we get stuck on and
that's a very clear symptom of ADHD and
so,
but it can also be part of anxiety and
if we take a step back and say what else
is going on,
what other things does this look like?
And kind of keep some
of these things in mind.
It helps us sort of decide one way or
another because when you start to pay
attention to the kids are doing
and like, as you know, right,
you can start to see like maybe
they are anxious about these things.
I never thought about the fact that he
was asking about the doors or whatever it
was or the coffee pot being on or the
oven being on. But now I think about it.
That makes sense.
So this is like some observational piece.
The testing is also super helpful because
it just gives a cognitive outline of
how they're doing. And so even if you
don't do like the psych piece, let's say,
let's say you're just doing
the neuro sake, you know,
all of their executive
functions could be great.
They can like totally do so well
on the attentional measures.
So then it's something else and then
we wonder how we find out about the
something else. And so that's kind of
how we negotiate it, at least on our end.
I don't know if that
answers your question. Okay.
Um, I wonder if you can speak to the
differences that you might see in the,
in the, um, you know, the
treatment of boys versus girls. Um,
I have three daughters and one of
them has one I think is probably Gad.
So I'm just curious if, if you have
any idea about the gender differences.
Sure. When kids are pretty
young, they actually,
the gender difference just in general
is less than when they get older,
obviously. So a lot of what we're doing
for younger kids is pretty much the same,
I would say.
Um,
are you talking in terms of treatment or
just sort of how it manifest outwardly?
Oh, she's a tween, if you will.
Sure. Um, well it's hard
with girls too, right?
Because that's sort of how we are
at that age a little bit, right?
There's a lot of that
stuff that goes on anyway.
And so it's a little hard to differentiate
between what's normal developmentally
appropriate stuff and
what is something else.
So I think in terms of
what you see at that age,
you do see differences because girls
are unfortunately because of gender
stereotypes and things like that,
they are more likely to be talking
about their feelings or yeah.
Or at least expressing them, whether
they're telling you why or not, you know,
they're crying or yelling.
They slammed the door in your face.
They do all these things were got,
got like boys tend to be a little more
inward in that or they become sort of the
like all the way down the other
spectrum of sort of more explosive.
So there's less talking about feelings
and things like that. So they're either,
you know,
sometimes like beating up their brother
and sister or they're just isolating
themselves in their rooms.
But there's not a lot of discussion about
those things because that's not really
something that we,
unfortunately we don't really promote
that in our society for the most part.
So if you're talking about tween age,
that's kind of where that stuff
starts a little bit. As a treater,
we would be doing a
lot of the same things.
And the way in is just a
little bit different, you know,
cause the guys come in sometimes,
and it's true for women too,
but it tends to be the teenage boys come
in and they're made to come to therapy
and f you and I'm not doing this.
And so how you like connect with that
person is a lot different than someone
who's a little more tearful or who wants
to tell you at least something about
their day or something like that.
Which the girls tend to be a little bit
more like, at least in my experience,
I have a six year old boy and he's
acting like a teenager because he doesn't
want to tell us anything about his day.
And like sometimes things get
out like eh randomly like so,
um, and, and I think that things
are bothering him. Um, um,
I mean he used to talk about it
more when he was younger then it
shut down.
So what can you do to trigger or kids
to talk about their day and they're the
top a little bit more about what scares
them if they face anxiety during the
day.
Yes. That's a tricky one
because he's probably younger.
Half this is not so true,
but as kids get older or like they are
less interested in talking to their
parents and so a lot of efforts
to facilitate that stuff when,
especially when you
have teenagers goes on,
it is not very fruitful I guess
you're ever so tend to be fruitful.
And that's when I tend to say,
you know,
maybe it's worth at least
seeing if there's somebody else,
like a school counselor or a coach or a
therapist or somebody that could kind of
get involved if you think
that's something's going on. Um,
I'm trying to think of how to
answer that question as a parent,
the kid who's not, well, I mean, I again,
I speak on like from the perspective
of the teacher and um, I,
I don't know,
I know every school is different,
but just sort of asking if teachers
have seen something similar.
Is there a teacher or an aide or
whatever it is that they do talk to?
Are they seeing, um, because I,
I made a lot of plugs about
parents communicating to us,
but I know that at
least for me personally,
there were times when I definitely
could have communicated things better to
parents. And it's not till the
email that I'm like, Oh yeah,
I should have mentioned to them that like,
I've noticed,
particularly at lunchtime,
you know,
you say are really shuts down or she
doesn't want to go to the cafeteria.
She does want to go
outside. Um, so you know,
maybe seeing especially you
said that younger your son, um,
what are they seeing? Are they, you know,
having the time of their lives at school
and then kind of a little different at
home. My brother was
definitely that way. Um, there,
my parents thought their kindergarten
teacher was talking about like a different
child. They're like,
no, that's not our son.
The one who's like super happy at school.
Like it's not so that,
I mean they can be good resources. I know
some teachers do it better than others.
Well I would also add, just
to answer the question, um,
I think a lot of times kids also don't
know that they're able or not able to do
things. So, and they don't have
the vocabulary to do it either.
So a lot of what we do for younger
kids is sort of teaching them feelings,
words and h and also how like some tea
or feelings in their like body sensations
are correlated to emotions. Love.
Sometimes we get angry, we get really hot,
you know, we feel like we're
sweaty or whatever it is.
And having them start to be a little more
self aware about those things because
sort of similar to the sematic
symptoms we were talking about,
kids don't necessarily,
they just know that something's
wrong and they don't know,
like it's not really their stomach,
it's not really a headache,
but they don't want to go to schools.
They're upset and so
they don't necessarily,
it just that they don't
have the language for it.
So that's something that would might be
a good place to start is just sort of
making it known that he's
allowed to do these things.
Like talk about his feelings. Maybe you
can write them down or maybe you know,
maybe it's at this one time of day,
but also sort of helping them
figure out how to do that.
I think that tends to be a pretty good
place to start because that's mostly what
we ended up doing in the
beginning because kids just don't,
and it's not their fault,
it's just developmentally just haven't
learned that stuff yet or draw.
I definitely have kids. I mean
personally, that's my coping.
But like I have kids who sometimes they,
they won't write about it,
especially if they're a bit younger,
but like they'll draw about it or you
can just like draw how you're feeling and
yeah,
maybe they start tearing up the paper
and that can be very indicative and yeah.
So that can be one way for kids.
Yeah.
Anything is like a great starting
point for a conversation. So,
so when you were talking about
mindfulness and blowing bubbles, um,
what's your opinion on
video games for that?
My son loves to play Minecraft as sort of,
I think it's the,
forget everything else.
I think like everything in
moderation is important.
I can appreciate the technical
and interest of Minecraft. Um,
I also know that kids use it
as an escape mechanism often.
And so having something to focus
on and work on is one thing.
But then having it be kind of take over
other things or take over time where you
would be spending with your family or
interacting with friends outside or
playing outside or with
the dog or whatever it is,
they're sort of aligned there.
And I think finding where that is and
finding the reason behind like the
Minecraft because like a lot of kids find
it super interesting and I, I get that.
But there tends to be like sometimes
another component to it or it's a
distraction to put off doing homework
because they don't feel like they are good
at math or something like that.
Um,
and this is true for video games
in general and people kind of,
the newest thing is kind of talk about
kids who are addicted to video games.
And I like to think of it more as, you
know, not to say he's addicted to them,
but just as a concept, you know,
it's, there's a reason kids do things,
there's a reason we all do them. And Video
Games are great way to have, you know,
a world in which you can be successful
where you don't actually know anybody.
We sort of know that.
And we were like online friends that's
a little bit different and it's escapism
and you know,
a lot of kids who are depressed or,
or using it as a tool to sort of escape.
And so kind of wondering
about the utility of it,
I guess wouldn't be what I
would say about it. But it is a,
it's hard because it's also a social
thing where they're all doing it,
so you can't have them, not if they like
it, you don't want to say don't do it,
but you also don't want it to be what
they're doing. So, and Minecraft is,
I don't,
it's not for me,
but I get how it's really addictive
for other people in that way.
Like they're really into
it. Well, thank you.